[Music]  you know you love it  here's something brand new  divorce [ __ ] talk to encounters  yeah come on got back from this crazy  trip all of them girls  [Music]  saying anything that they wanted  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  that's the kind of action that i'm  talking about tequila  when life gets tough we figure it out  f-bomb on the g  do you know me  [Music]  this is  [Music]  they are the nature and we are the  forest it got kind of crazy but we  stayed the course i know there was drama  but i can't  [Music]  and beaches too it was heaven on earth  and that much is true  [Music]  do you know me  [Music]  private jets and i'll never forget the  way that we laughed you're welcome  you're  fine and the best wealthy  yet is how everyone loved it and then  got upset  oceans and photos with divas galore so  many selfies couldn't take anymore flash  sailing the yacht from the sea to the  shore with all of the  [Music]  with the ogs  you all know what it is  you